from Bond girls to pop stars to even a
Jedi a lot of people have been
considered for the role of Laura Croft
here's who almost brought the famous
treasure hunter to
life back when the first Tomb Raider
movie was in development in the late
1990s Denise Richards emerged as an
early front runner for the part though
she may not be as well known today as
some of the other actors on this list
Richards was a rapidly rising star at
the time she'd recently starred in Paul
ver hovind's sci-fi classic Starship
Troopers and more significantly played
Bond girl Christmas Jones in 1999's the
World is Not Enough opposite Pierce
broen her role in the Spy flick in
particular made Richards a strong choice
to play Laura Croft in the eyes of the
public and rumors quickly spread that
she was a Sho in for the part in fact
the Christmas Jones character resembled
Croft so explicitly that some accused
the film of stealing the video game
characters design after seeing the film
even idos interactive executive John
Davis told the guardian
she is Lara she's tough determined and
has buckets of attitude whether the
similarity is intentional or not there
is no doubt bond has fallen for our girl
in the end of course Richards didn't get
the part though early reports made it
sound like she had it in the bag
director Simon West later said that he
had always wanted Angelina Jolie for the
role there may not have been a brighter
rising star in Hollywood in the late
'90s than Jennifer Lopez after becoming
well known as a dance on In Living Color
she leveraged her Fame to land leading
roles in movies like Anaconda Selena and
out of sight all of which helped rocket
her to fame it should be no surprise
then that Lopez was in the running for a
role as juicy as Laura Croft multiple
sources placed Lopez on the list of
would be Lara and Paramount Pictures
considered her a strong Contender Simon
West ultimately went in a different
direction for the character but it's
doubtful that Lopez lost much sleep over
Angelina Jolie getting the part today
she's a multi media icon and one of the
most successful performers of the 21st
century had she landed the role in Tomb
Raider it likely would have become just
a footnote on her long and impressive
resume much like the role of Laura Croft
is for Jolie today I bet by the end of
the 90s Ashley Jud had established
herself as a force to be reckoned with
in the crime Thriller genre starring in
films like heat with alcino and Robert
dairo and double jeopardy with Tommy Lee
Jones as the search for Laura croft's
liveaction equivalent spread far and
wide someone with such a solid
reputation for suspenseful action
performances was a natural Contender to
fill Laura croft's combat boots while
the role ultimately went to Jolie Jud
managed to assemble her own impressive
filmography she's appeared in movies
like olympus' Fallen the Divergent
adaptations and both Dolphin Tale movies
she has also had a pretty stacked TV
career appearing in the likes of Berlin
Station and Twin Peaks the return in the
process she's proven she's the right
choice for many acting rol RS but
apparently not Laura
Croft Katherine Zeta Jones had been
acting for a decade when casting for
Laura Croft Tomb Raider kicked off but
she had just recently achieved her big
breakthrough in the mask of Zoro the
Martin Campbell feature was a huge hit
and launched her to start him placing
her in the running for the star role of
the video game adaptation unlike some of
the other contenders including Jolie
herself Zeta Jones actually came from
the right side of the Atlantic to play
the part of Lura Croft the famed Fortune
is notably British and though Zita Jones
is actually from Wales she's a great
deal closer to Lara's Homeland than
Denise Richards or Ashley Jud though she
didn't end up playing Laura Zeta Jones
did have a hugely successful decade in
the 2000s what did you say the mask of
Zoro led to films like High Fidelity
traffic Oceans 12 and the Broadway
adaptation Chicago today Zeta Jones is
still considered one of the biggest
stars of that era and she didn't need a
starring turn in a video game adaptation
to make that Riz to fous happened still
it's hard to deny that she probably
would have been quite good in the
role any list of Hot Shot brunette
action stars from the late 90s would be
incomplete without the inclusion of
Dutch actor FKA Jansen like fellow Loft
Contender Denise Richards Jansen had
made a name for herself in the 1990s by
playing a Bond girl specifically
assassin zenya onop in 1995 golden eye
though that film is arguably more famous
these days for the Beloved video game it
spawned that connect to interactive
media didn't help Jansen land the part
still it's easy to see why Jansen was
strongly considered for the role by
Paramount Pictures not only had she
co-starred in one of the most successful
007 films of the era but she'd followed
that appearance up with other hits like
the poker Thriller rounders and the 1999
horror flick House on Haunted Hill
though she missed out on Tomb Raider
Jansen got her hooks into an even bigger
2000s franchise when she landed the role
of Jean Gray and X-Men that part led to
repeat appearances throughout the rest
of the initial X-Men film Trilogy and
though her grand finale in 2006's X-Men
the Last Stand was critically panned
Jansen herself is great in it she stayed
active in recent years with turns and
shows like Netflix's Hemlock Grove and
ABC's how to get away with murder but
will always wonder what her Twist on the
Laura Croft character would have looked
like though she was barely in her early
20s when casting for Laura Croft Tomb
Raider was going on Jennifer Love hwit
was already a veteran actor a steady gig
on Disney's Kids Incorporated led to a
breakout role on the hit teen drama
series Party of Five in 1995 in addition
to some other TV work QT made her mark
on the big screen with 1997's I Know
What You Did Last Summer appearing
alongside fellow '90s heartthrobs Sarah
Michelle Geller Ryan philippy and Freddy
Prince Jr with such a well-defined
background it's no surprise she was in
talks to bring Laura Croft to life she
had the look the resume and the cultural
clout though like so many of the other
contenders she lacked a legitimate
British Heritage trust me it's not
anything you want to hear about huitt
may not have landed the role of Laura
Croft but she has had a busy 21st
century nonetheless staying true to her
roots she's never stopped acting on
television she's had major roles in
shows like Criminal Minds 911 The Client
List and she famously starred in Ghost
Whisperer She's been a bit less active
on the big screen over the past decade
but that doesn't mean she couldn't
return someday
soon while many of the actors on this
list were Rising Stars at the turn of
the Millennium Sandra Bullock had
already built a hefty list of starring
roles before the release of Laura Croft
Tomb Raider by 2001 she was a proven box
office Powerhouse who'd starred
alongside some of the biggest names of
the decade what's more she was still
considered an action star at the time
thanks to her performances in films like
speed and Demolition Man though she
ultimately wound up leaving that genre
in favor of meteor material according to
isel's Casting might have BS a film by
film directory of actors considered for
roles given to others Bullock was in the
running for Laura Croft given her
current profile as an Oscar winning
dramatic actor it's hard to imagine her
doing all the swan diving and Grave
robbing in the video game adaptation
though the same could be said for
Angelina Jolie clearly Bullock had
another path to take one that's led her
into the hallowed Halls of Film Academy
history and made her one of the most
acclaimed actresses of her
generation whether or not Dei Moore was
actually in the running for the role of
Laura Croft is Up For Debate while some
film historians have reported producers
were considering her it may have been
more rumor than fact regardless her name
was thrown around frequently after the
Tomb Raider movie was first announced of
everyone on this list more may have been
the most established performer at the
time as well as one of the oldest actors
supposedly in the running she was
already a star in the 80s thanks to
movies like about last night in St Elmo
fire and in the '90s she starred in
everything from Ghost and Indecent
Proposal to A Few Good Men Moore had
enough Fame and physical similarity to
Lara that it makes sense why her name
was bandied around so much regarding the
role however it's hard to imagine her as
a real Contender as she may have been
too established at the time to stoop to
a video game adaptation a genre that
took decades to become anything more
than a
gimmick the last major actor heavily
rumored to have been in the mix for
Laura Croft Tomb Raider is Jerry Ryan
Who Rose to Fame in the late '90s for
playing the Borg Refugee turned Starship
crew member seven of nine on Star Trek
Voyager because of the immense weight
that playing Seven gave her in nerd
culture at the time she was discussed by
fans online as a likely pick to play the
digital treasure hunter it's unclear
whether those fan rumors actually
emerged from the actual casting process
but regardless Ryan didn't wind up with
a part Ryan has never become much of a
movie star but she's been a staple on TV
ever since her tenure on Voyager shark
leverage Boston Public Body of Proof
and many other shows have benefited from
her talents and of course she reprised
her beloved Star Trek character starting
in 2020 in Star Trek
beard when it came time to reboot the
Tomb Raider film franchise after
Angelina Jolie's duy several names Rose
to the top of the rumor mill it wasn't
quite the circus that the '90s casting
call was but quite a few big names were
thrown around before Alysia Vander
finally landed the par back in 2011 when
talks of a reboot were first making the
rounds some fans speculated that Olivia
wild was going to take up the mantle of
Laura Croft what more could a guy want
wild herself later refuted these claims
and it would still be many years before
the next Tomb Raider movie actually made
it theaters in the early 2010s though
you'd be hard press to find a better fit
for the role than wild she was coming
Fresh Off backto back Sci-Fi Action
roles in Tron legacy and Cowboys and
Aliens and she had the exact kind of
Charisma that fans had come to associate
with the character though she's
continued to be a prolific actor despite
never playing Laura Croft while
transitioned to more behind the camera
work in the late 2010s gaining
widespread a claim for directing
booksmart in 2019 and following it up
with the controversially received don't
worry darling in
2022 as early as 2009 Megan Fox was
already being rumored to replace
Angelina Jolie and reboot the franchise
essentially Sports even reported that
fox was actually straight up offer the
role having risen to immense fi after
appearing in the first two Transformers
movies but turned it down these claims
are difficult to verify but it's true
that fox was a popular Fan cast for the
role of Lura for many years if she did
in fact turn down the role there are
plenty of good reasons why fox has been
outspoken in more recent years about how
harmful her sexualized Public Image was
to her mental health given a sexist
nature with which the character of Laura
Croft was seen for so long it would make
sense that fox wanted nothing to do with
the part even so fox has continued to be
a staple in action adventure genre Fair
she appeared in movies like Jonah Hex
and the liveaction Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles films in addition to a number of
smaller more artistic films and some TV
appearances the Tomb Raider reboot Megan
Fox and Olivia wild were in talks for
never actually materialized but when
talks started the surface about the 2018
Tomb Raider film Star Wars Alum Daisy
Ridley was a potential choice for the
lead Ridley confirmed to Empire in 2016
that she been in conversations about
starring in the reboot but those talks
evaporated completely by
2017 what's the craziest rumor that
you've ever heard about yourself that I
was going to play Loft and Tomb Raider
given how open she had previously been
about the role it's unclear what
eventually ended those conversations
regardless the part ultimately went to
viander though viander did a great job
in 2018s Tomb Raider it's easy to
imagine Ridley in the role out of all
the might of bends on this list she's
arguably the best f for the character's
more grounded modern
[Music]
incarnation